today's one minute monday is practice if
you're just starting off at something
chances are you're going to suck at it
you're not going to be really good but
you get better food practice and don't
give up when it's hard when I first
started doing my radio show for example
I remember the first 1i maybe practice
100 200 times I don't know how many
times I was in New York I was stressed
out you know wanted to be successful is
excited and and it was pretty good but
over the course of time now I've gotten
better at it and I don't need to
practice as much I've a radio show
tomorrow I've written a few notes down
I'm going to go from that I don't need
to go through it 200 times when i first
started snowboarding it sucked every
time i got up i fell i got up i fell i
got up i fell it's not just frustrating
that you're not getting it and hurt i'm
falling on my butt it hurt but now i can
get up and and go and not fall because i
have the practice so whatever you're
trying to learn now whatever new skill
you trying to pick up the beginning
stages they're hard it's frustrating it
sucks but don't give up because if you
keep practicing you're going to get
better and better and better and soon it
won't hurt as much you won't follow us
much you won't make us any mistakes it's
going to be easier and you'll see more
results believe so those are you
watching like the video give it a thumbs
up below and let me know what you think
leave a comment subscribe thank you so
much and I'll see you soon